alemania se confina nuevamente señalando
un crecimiento exponencial de las
infecciones así como un drástico aumento
en la cifra de muertes
angela merkel apretó las tuercas a las
medidas y restricciones de cara a la
temporada navideña
a partir del miércoles 16 de diciembre
cerraremos las tiendas excepto las de
comestibles y otros artículos esenciales
no se permitiera la venta de artículos
no esenciales en las tiendas de
comestibles
en una resolución adoptada por el
gobierno federal y los 16 estados
regionales se pide a los empleadores que
den a sus trabajadores la mayor
prioridad posible al teletrabajo oa las
vacaciones el gobierno ha prometido
ayudas de hasta 11 millones de euros al
mes para amortiguar el golpe de un nuevo
cierre para los comerciantes muchos
parecen sin embargo estar de acuerdo con
las medidas artist phone
acabo de ver a la canciller en la
televisión y creo que tiene razón en que
hay diferentes intereses que debemos
considerar no nos ayudará ahora así que
mirando hacia atrás si lo hubiéramos
sabido probablemente hubiéramos tomado
medidas
fuertes antes no
bares y restaurantes ya estaban cerrados
desde noviembre por un confinamiento
parcial como parte de las medidas no se
podrá vender alcohol en la vía pública
tampoco será autorizado la venta de
fuegos artificiales ni las reuniones en
espacios públicos para nochebuena
nochevieja otra medida importante los
colegios permanecerán cerrados hasta el
10 de enero si no tenemos cuidado
alemania se convertirá en el niño
problemático de europa alguien muere de
coronavirus en alemania cada tres
minutos probablemente será la tercera
causa de muerte más común este año son
rinitis móvil
alemania se vio relativamente poco
afectada por la primera ola de la
pandemia pero enfrenta problemas para
contener la segunda el país ya cuenta
con más de 1.300.000 casos confirmados y
casi 22.000 muertes y con la llegada del
invierno las autoridades no prometen que
la economía pueda reabrir después del 10
de enero